you make $500,000 a month I don't
believe it because I believe you make a
lot more than that on a good month I was
working a full-time job at noodles and
company taking college classes and
streaming like eight hours a day minimum
I know a lot of people who have gotten
to a position that I am in and they just
get like complacent you know pump the
brakes and I'm not gonna I'm gonna do
that at all need motivation watch a top
ten with believe nation what's up
elevation seven I believe in you and
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine so let's get
your motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a second showing
today's lessons from a man in one from
being a kid with a passion for video
games to becoming the biggest twitch
streamer internet celebrity and a highly
successful professional eSports player
who earns over half a million dollars
per month from streaming for tonight
he's Richard Tyler and ninja Blevins and
here's my take on his top ten little
success enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one follow your wash fortnight is a
survival video game where a hundred
players battle against each other to be
the last one standing
however ninja doesn't just play for
tonight he's devoted his life to it oh
my god let's go it's something that was
super passion about I always came I
always started I started to shoot when I
was 18 or 19 and I just never stopped do
you remember the moment where you
realized I can actually make a living in
a very good living doing this I think I
was twenty years old when I was making
enough money to stop going to college
and then I quit my job at new dozen
company and then once I started making
like really good money that's when I was
like alright I can kind of just put
everything on the side and just focus on
the streaming rule number two commit
fully
[Music]
[Applause]
do you know how many hours you've
streamed this year fortnight alone is
like 3400 or 3,800 of fortnight that's
this year 142 days of sure 142 days of
stream of gaming and streaming yet one
of the things that blew people's mind in
this article was the quote that you make
$500,000 a month I don't believe it
because I believe you make a lot more
than that on a good one and it was when
you were making 80 or 90 a year that you
decided I can get out of college and I
can quit noodles and comfort it right
that was the deciding factor was my mom
you know by no means was she gonna let
me quit my job or drop out of school
then I say that like that like drop out
of school I don't even like that cuz I
always had every intention of going back
I actually did go back when I had like a
I issue thing my stream took a dive but
yeah after the 80 was like 80,000 a year
I was like mom I'm doing this until you
know if I stop if I make less I'll go
back could you be the first ten million
dollar a year gamer definitely rule
number three be resilient believe in
yourself and work hard know what you're
worth know what you're capable of and
anything could happen resilience is very
important I
I had like tragedy after gotta lock
after missed opportunity after missed
opportunity for streaming my entire like
career until like h1z1 and pub G and and
I just never stopped because I knew that
if I just kept trying I knew that at
some point I would go from point A to
point B right I knew my skill like I
knew I knew what I was capable of I knew
how talented I was at gaming and I just
knew that if I just kept like you know
like I always had long talks of my life
and in my bowl my now wife my girlfriend
at the time jess and my brothers and and
like we always came to the conclusion
that like like I just need to keep
streaming I just need to keep going and
at some point like something like like
you'll take off and at some point rule
number four seize your moments on March
15th and online explosion occurred when
ninja was joined by hip-hop artist Drake
for a game of fortnight GI Drake Drake
wanted a game he was just like hey man
how'd he reach out to Instagram in DMD
oh yeah and he said I won't find you
were like this is the actual Drake we
thought he got hacked
yes my body got act for sure we were
like there's no way there's just
absolutely no way and then some random
Wednesday he's just like yo I'm on this
play I was like one fan moment my wife
wants to say hello
[Music]
let's go baby
that set me on the path of being where I
am today as quickly as it did I think
that I could have gotten here what are
you taking away longer
you know Drake making that moment that
made it cool if you will rule number
five make sacrifices need opinion I'm
going to college for four days I'm
freaking out I don't know if I really
want to go love making YouTube videos
but I've run out of time to grow I
disagree that you've run out of time to
grow listen do you have any idea you're
gonna have time in college to do both
you're gonna have time I want you to
know that I'll just not going to take up
16 hours of your day okay I promise you
that especially if this is like your
first year first year of college you're
not gonna you're not gonna have eight
hours of classes every single day you're
gonna have so much time to still make
youtube videos men you might have to
sacrifice hanging out with friends and
going out and partying and and doing
other cool things that the school and
college has to offer you can't say that
dude I I was I was working a full-time
job at noodles and company taking
college classes and streaming like eight
hours a day minimum its success is
sacrifice man if you are not born into
being successful and you've become
successful you sacrifice something well
there be time with friends time with
family your physical health sometimes I
do they get very difficult to make
incredible journeys of growth in ever in
multiple ways and completely keep
everything it's not possible rule number
six offers something unique
I played the incredulous non techie
person congratulations on getting people
to pay so much money that you bring in
more than half a million dollars in
revenue a month they can watch you play
video games why do they want to watch
you play I think that I offer a
combination of high game play like high
to your game play that they really can't
get with a lot of other content creators
it's very difficult to be like one of
the best that
a videogame in any game or at anything
at all in the world and I also think I
offer I mean I'm very goofy if you've
ever watched any of my streams of my
youtube videos I do impressions and like
stuff like that all the time and just
crazy shenanigans and I think that the
combination of that it's like a hybrid
and it's just really fun to watch in a
pretty positive environment as well
rule number seven find your gift a lot
of athletes will tell me they had a
moment when they were playing that they
realized wait I'm really good at this
not just I'm better than most of my
friends but I am right you're really
good at this
is there that kind of moment in gaming
did you have it yeah no I think it was
it was a long time ago I was a kid like
16 or 15 we would always have lands
whenever the new halo would come out and
as I got older we would have more more
people come over and I would just I just
you know smacked all my friends and my
brothers just destroyed them all at that
like the very first day the game came
out and it was that and then a couple
months later there's like this local
tournament or not a local terminal but a
term that came out and like the magic
just for Halo and I ended up being like
one of the top-ranked and that just
without even like trying I just wanted
to play in the playlist it was a demo
more I was like okay like these are like
the best players I'm competing with them
like I might have something
remember be ambitious and consider
yourself the best gamer in the world I
would never say that about myself now
because I think that if you do then that
means like there's no room to grow that
makes sense
you want to be considered the greatest
gamer of all time yes so when you think
of the NBA
you know there you got you know you got
your Michael Jordan LeBron James so I
think it's just like the legacy that
they left is something that I am just
striving for I know a lot of people who
have gotten to a position that I am in
and they just get like complacent you
know pump the brakes and I'm not gonna
not gonna do that
battle rule number nine be highly
competitive I just wanna be better than
everybody else deep like I want to be
the number one ranked I wanna be higher
than everyone some people go to work
they work eight hours or however long
they're gonna work and they make their
money they work for it right I'm not
just sitting here playing video games be
like oh oh good now it's like you have
to be better than hundreds of people
thousands of people you have to be the
best player to win money from
tournaments and rule number ten the last
one before a very special bonus clip is
have fun I want to look for this guy
Malone landing on the balloon 360 often
knows go ahead better country okay
[Music]
[Music]
we somebody clipped that whole thing
please you guys can get this awesome
dance by the way if you link twitch
Prime accounts here at the games account
the switch prime skin or twitch Prime
dance just do it now got a special bonus
clip from ninja on how to be smart with
your money that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three point lighting questions time to
move from just watching another video to
taking action in your life or business
and you're feeling bold leave your
answers in the comments below here we go
question number one what is your passion
and your gift number two what moment do
you need to seize right now and number
three what is the unique thing that you
offer
I think we're preaching good personal
finance it's great much to speak people
to learn young before they make mistakes
trying to live above their means I mean
dude stay in your lane man do you just
gotta you just gotta stay in your lane
you know and again what that means this
is like you know your your your your
financial lane right you're making
$100,000 a year like you drive in this
Lane you spend this amount of money on
this amount of things you know like you
stay in your lane you don't try to hang
out and spend a lot of money and act
like you make this much money okay which
this is like the 1 million this is 10
million this
stay in your lane dude all right like
and one thing that a lot of you want to
do is just is just these gotta be smart
with your money man you have to be small
with your money you should be saving
money you're a little kid I didn't buy
anything other than video games when I
was little right so I just put all my
money away into my bank account man I
had like by the time I was like ready
for college I think I'm saved up like 20
grand I got you know my grandma I had
like I think $5,000 for ten thousand
dollars saved up for us my parents had a
little bit saved up like after I burned
through that in like a year and a half
of college like you just yet but like
you've just gotta save it as it goes so
fast
if you like this video check out the top
10 I need on the pewdiepie the link is
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there
I didn't enjoy what I was doing and it
felt like it didn't have a purpose of me
doing it so the future for me was
something really like ah